und die bundesverteidigungsministerin
ist derzeit auf einem vorweihnachtlichen
Truppenbesuch bei deutschen Soldaten in
der Slowakei guten Abend Frau lambrecht
schönen guten Abend Frau Lanka was
machen wir denn jetzt mit diesem Pumas
einstampfen das ganze Projekt der
Industrie die Mangelware zurückgeben und
was anderes kaufen was praxisstauglich
ist
also ich erwarte jetzt dass die Pumas
die fehlerhaft sind die jetzt
festgestellt wurden schnellstmöglich
schnellstmöglich von der Industrie
instand gesetzt werden das ist der erste
Schritt das hilft uns aber dauerhaft
nicht weiter sondern ich erwarte eine
Perspektive wie wir verlässlich mit
diesen Pumas rechnen können wie man also
verlässlich diese Fehler beheben kann
wir können uns nicht immer von einer
Instandsetzung zur anderen handeln
sondern wir brauchen verlässliche
Lösungen oder die Entscheidung nicht
mehr länger auf den Puma zu setzen das
ist eine Entscheidung dir zum Beispiel
die Holländer vor Raumzeit als man auch
merkte welche Probleme ist mit diesem
Projekt gehabt diese Mängel sind ja alle
nicht neu wir hatten schon 2015 Probleme
mit dem Puma da kam irgendwie Wasser ins
Kanonenrohr und ähnliches also da sind
die Holländer ja zum Beispiel
ausgestiegen und haben lieber was
praktisches und nicht ganz so
hochgerüstetes in Schweden gekauft weil
das nicht vielleicht für uns auch eine
Lösung
wir haben in den letzten Jahren und bei
verschiedenen Übungen eigentlich
vielversprechende Ergebnisse erzielt mit
dem Puma von daher glaube ich ist es
doch noch mal die Mühe wert mit der
Industrie zu beraten ob es denn in
irgendeiner Weise Verlässlichkeit geben
kann das muss aber sehr zügig gehen denn
wir haben Verpflichtungen und die wollen
wir auch innerhalb der NATO einhalten
und deswegen ist jetzt aktuell die
Forderung an die Industrie erstens
instandsetzen dieser Pommes die jetzt
gerade aufgefallen sind und darüber
hinaus uns ein Konzept vorzulegen aber
das muss sehr schnell gehen und wenn es
nicht funktioniert wenn es nicht möglich
ist dann müssen tatsächlich andere
Entscheidungen nehmen ganz kurz gefragt
setzen sie da eine Frist dass sie sagen
bis dahin will ich ein Ergebnis sehen
oder wir schwenken um
ja das wird keineswegs mehr Monate
dauern können die Instandsetzung die
muss sehr schnell gehen da erwarte ich
also auch keine keine Zusagen innerhalb
vieler Wochen sondern innerhalb weniger
und bei der Verlässlichkeit ja da
erwarte ich tatsächlich dass wir in
wenigen Wochen auch uns dann auf eine
Lösung verständigen können denn
ansonsten kann ich die Verantwortung
nicht übernehmen wir müssten ansonsten
investieren in eine Nachrüstung diese
Verträge werden wir nicht unterschreiben
und auch ein zweites los sprich weitere
Bestellungen wird es nicht geben
deswegen Schnelligkeit ist jetzt gefragt
die Industrie ist in der Pflicht und
diesen Weg werden wir gemeinsam gehen
oder dann ihn eben auch abbrechen wenn
es sein muss Schnelligkeit bräuchte die
Bundeswehr ja auch bei anderen
Beschaffungen also Munition zum Beispiel
jetzt haben wir seit 10 Monaten diesen
Angriffskrieg aber nicht die
entsprechenden Geschosse für Geparden
oder Panzerhaubitzen besorgt und stehen
da jetzt in der Warteschleife warum
dauert das denn bei Ihnen im Haus so
lange
den Gepard den hatten wir schon längst
ausgepreist den gibt es den gab es bei
der Bundeswehr gar nicht mehr und zwar
schon sehr lange und alles was wir an
Munition haben hatten wir an die Ukraine
geliefert deswegen ist das wirklich eine
Situation die die erwartet dass wir
jetzt eine neue Produktionsstätte
auflegen also nicht wir sondern die
Industrie und da kommt Bewegung rein das
auch dieses System wieder entsprechend
bestückt werden kann aber ansonsten sind
wir unter Hochdruck daran Munition zu
beschaffen mit allen Möglichkeiten die
sich uns bietet jetzt ist endlich auch
das Geld da das heißt die
Haushaltsmittel stehen zur Verfügung und
deswegen kann auch beschafft werden aber
es ist tatsächlich so ja wir haben auch
in den letzten Monaten sehr viel
abgegeben an die Ukraine weil wir sie in
ihrem mutigen Kampf in diesem brutalen
Angriffskrieg unterstützt haben dann
sieht man gerade wenn man Blick in die
Ukraine auch mit Videos dort von den von
den ähm Kriegsszenarien wie dringend
schützen Panzer gebraucht werden und
auch welche die nicht nur antik sind wir
unsere Marder dann irgendwann wenn da
Infanterie quasi ungeschützt übers Feld
läuft dann hatte die Ukraine ja die
Hoffnung von uns irgendwann auch Marder
zu bekommen kann sie die Hoffnung jetzt
begraben weil die Bundeswehr die die
noch bei der Industrie stehen jetzt für
sich selber braucht
also aus der Bundeswehr werden wir ganz
bestimmt keine Mader abgehen sieht man
gerade jetzt wieder in der in dieser
Situation und wir helfen mit dass die
Ukraine Panzer geliefert bekommt ich bin
hier gerade in der Slowakei und von hier
wurden werden Panzer abgegeben 30 noch
sowjetischer Bauart und wir helfen
wiederum dass dann in der Slowakei diese
Lücken geschlossen werden der sogenannte
Ringtausch es ist wichtig dass es
schnell geht das schnell geliefert
werden kann aber was die Ukraine ganz
dringend braucht ist Luftverteidigung
sie müssen sich gegen diesen Raketen
gegen diesen Drohnen Terror verteidigen
könnte deswegen ist beispielsweise unser
System ihres Tee so wichtig und das im
nächsten Jahr auch wenn die Industrie
dann liefert auch weitere Systeme kommen
dass unser gepaart schützen kann die
kritische Infrastruktur und
Luftverteidigung Atelier das ist wichtig
und die Ukraine zu unterstützen in der
Durchhaltefähigkeit und auch deshalb bin
ich hier in der Slowakei wir haben hier
einen instandsetzungshub jetzt hier
einrichten können etwas schneller unsere
Waffensysteme die wir in die Ukraine
geliefert haben auch wieder reparieren
zu können wenn es denn notwendig ist und
natürlich bei dem Einsatz bei dem
Gebrauch ist es notwendig und es ist
schnell gelungen damit die Wege kurz
sind die Ukraine so zu unterstützen
dadurch dass schnell entstand gesetzt
werden kann und dann weiter gekämpft
werden kann voll lange recht danke für
das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen